ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre je voudrais revenir sur
un incident qui s'est déroulé en fin de
semaine dernière au sénat
ou plus exactement à l'extérieur du
sénat au lendemain de la fin du congrès
des maires et qui nous semble grave pour
leur respect de nos institutions
après avoir écouté les discours
nos élus locaux ont dressé un bilan
implacable le compte n'y est pas les
maires ont l'habitude d'agir ils
agissent quotidiennement sur le terrain
pendant que le président gesticule
solennellement depuis l'elysée quand le
sénat travaille à mettre de l'huile dans
les rouages de la république le
gouvernement répond par des déclarations
des tweets mettant de l'huile sur le feu
par des raccourcis malvenue après le
rapport de mathieu darnaud et de jean
marie bockel notre amendement
d'ouverture en faveur des maires des
petites communes chercher à rétablir une
injustice passé sans cynisme ni
populisme juste de la justice monsieur
le premier ministre la situation du pays
est fragile la crise démocratique cours
les menaces populistes sont aussi
présentes en france
votre silence après le tweet malheureux
du ministre des comptes publics vendredi
et des déclarations incongrues des ports
des du porte parole du gouvernement ce
matin mérite est une réponse de soutien
aux élus de la république et au
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
alors monsieur le premier ministre
quelles mesures allez vous prendre
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui et pas demain pour nos
fantassins de la république que sont les
maires de france
quelles consignes allez vous donnez à
votre gouvernement afin qu'ils
respectent la république
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur gérald darmanin mais une liste
de l'action des comptes publics
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur pro
ministre m'a demandé ma autorisé à vous
répondre monsieur pas cher puisqu'il me
semble être légèrement concernés par
votre question il ya la fia le fond il
ya la forme
permettez-moi d'abord de revenir sur ce
qui est sans doute le plus important en
tout cas quand on la littérature c'est
le style est ce que pour ma part
j'aurais dû être au sénat vendredi
même si olivier du soft me représenter
représente dignement sans doute
aurais-je dû être à votre à ma place au
banc cela aurait permis sans doute
d'avoir gardé la même réponse sur le
fond qu'importe négative ou était dans
ma commune c'est vrai à accueillir deux
ministres pour parler d'un grand projet
novateur urbaine parce que je le dis
bien volontiers
je le dis bien volontiers je le dis bien
volontiers
monsieur le président j'aurais dû être
au sénat mais il est vrai que de temps
en temps j'ai une petit à petit roeulx
mort parce que je suis aussi comme vous
et lui j'ai été maire et je fais
d'ailleurs partie du corps électoral qui
élit les sénateurs et je comprends vos
questions monsieur les amateurs et donc
il est vrai si je puis me permettre
parce que j'ai avait apprécié la façon
dont nous avons des relations monsieur
le sénateur comme beaucoup ici
gilles est vrai que au lieu de faire des
tweets il vaut mieux dire en face les
choses vous avez raison et c'est tout à
fait vrai d'ailleurs je n'ai pas voulu
jeudi au sénateur d'allier lire ça
aurait été tout à fait inconvenant et je
suis respectueux des institutions
monsieur le président du sénat et je
suis à la disposition de l'assemblée
parlementaire en tant que membre du
gouvernement
j'aurais pu aussi lire les très nombreux
tweets d' attaques personnelles
auxquelles j'ai eu droit non pas
avant-hier mais depuis un an ou un an et
demi et je n'ai pas fait parce que vous
avez raison il faut élever le débat sur
le fond monsieur le sénateur y at il un
problème de rémunération a notamment de
fiscalité depuis 2007
des élus des petites communes et non pas
des petits élus comme j'ai pu le lire
ici ou là la réponse est oui
est-ce que cet amendement correspondait
à l'exposé des motifs que vous avez
présenté l'honnêteté nous pousse à dire
que la réponse est non est-ce que lors
de la seconde délibération si monsieur
le président permet de terminer ces
quelques secondes
est-ce que la seconde délibération que
le sénat va demander le gouvernement
sera favorable pour être réussir comme
l'a demandé monsieur le premier ministre
l'incitation fiscale pour faire très
vite dès 1500 euros d'abattement jusqu'à
dix-huit mille euros la réponse est oui
pour les communes un détail les plus
réduites mais nous paraissait pas
raisonnable et avoué le avec moi de
concerner que les présidents de région
les présentes département les maires de
grandes villes dont j'ai été bénéficient
des mêmes avantages fiscaux que les
maires des communes les plus petites je
pourrais polar conclu un week-end
monsieur jérôme vacher pour quelques
secondes monsieur le ministre nous ne
voulons plus de double discours ni de
double langage les français par un
programme un langage clair
eux ils ont raison les élus attendent
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]